also viele Dinge gerade in Bewegung und
deswegen
bin ich auch so gespannt auf die Sendung
heute big auch auf Jens Spahn
klingt vielleicht etwas seltsam wenn man
jetzt nach Thüringen und zu AFD geht
aber auch da gibt es ja gerade im in der
afd-erzählung gibt ja immer diese diese
sehr distanzlose Erzählung zu Russland
also in den Augen von AFD Vertretern die
ich hier auch schon sitzen hatte ist
Putin eigentlich in Faller Kerl das
finde ich jetzt auch der größte Vorwurf
und eigentlich auch der Hauptpunkt der
mir vielleicht stärker auch ausarbeiten
sollten alle miteinander den an der AFD
machen kann neben dem dass sie
antisemitisch ist dass sie
fremdenfeindlich unterwegs ist dass sie
es und die Maus führt dass sie am Ende
eben auch Putin unterstützt diesen
Kriegstreiber diesen Menschen der mir
Millionen auf dem Gewissen hat was
Vergewaltigung angeht was Mord angeht
was Kinder Entführung aus der Ukraine
angeht und die lassen sich nach allem
was wir wissen in Teilen von ihm
finanzieren und reden ihm nach dem Mund
das er leben wir im Bundestag jede Woche
und ich finde das muss man auch immer
wieder deutlich machen das ist
eigentlich auch ein Stück Verrat am
eigenen Land und aber der Blick wirklich
in unser Land nach Thüringen Robert
Sesselmann ne der erste AFD Landesrat
warum
wählen über 50 %. oh Mann
einmal kurz schauen was ist da passiert
in Sonneberg sind 28.000 Menschen wählen
gegangen
am Ende haben 787 stimmen so rum oder so
rum entschieden ob der eine oder der
andere Kandidat gewählt wird er muss uns
das umtreiben ja Gerät deswegen die
Republik ins Wanken nein also ich finde
wichtig dahin zu schauen aber ich finde
auch wichtige Relation immer so schaut
was die letzten zwei Tage los ist dass
man das schon auch in einer Relation
sieht es ist übertrieben na ich finde
man muss halt einmal einordnen das ist
ein Landkreis 28000 Menschen sind wählen
gegangen 787 stimmen so rum oder so
haben darüber entschieden was passiert
übrigens in einem Land das seit 10
Jahren von einem linken regiert wird und
in einem Landkreis wo SPD Grüne und
links verteilt zusammen nicht mehr mehr
20% schaffen man muss ja wissen der
Vorgänger dieses AFD Mann ist den wir ja
gerade sehen über einen SPD Landrat und
insofern wenn man das mal alles so
zusammen nimmt ja klar müssen wir
analysieren was da passiert ist ich
empfehle nur immer nicht Bereich zuerst
die Empörung in der Analyse zu haben ist
auch gar keine Analyse mehr das ist ja
erstmal nur emotionales
auseinandersetzen sondern zuerst mal die
Frage zu stellen warum wie und warum
konnte das passieren und wie geht diese
Analyse ich kann die mir also ich bin
diese Woche tatsächlich sogar noch auf
Termin in Thüringen ich finde erstmal
immer wichtig auch vor Ort zu sein
zuzuhören aber offensichtlich haben
ziemlich viele Menschen einen ziemlichen
Frust ja es gibt Wählerinnen und Wähler
der AFD die rechtzeitigal sind die sie
auch deswegen wählen aber nach allem was
wir sehen und wissen ist dass er der
kleinere Teil zumal bei diesen
Prozentwerten wenn man einfach auch
schaut die weil die Wahlkampagne des
afd-kandidaten in Sonnenberg es wird
ausschließlich schauen Sie auf seine
plakata auf seine Flyer auf alles zwar
ausschließlich eine bundespolitische
Auseinandersetzung gegen die
Bundesregierung vom heizgesetz über
Migration und sonst was das Kulturkampf
ne das worüber wir heute machen
die Frage von Migration die Frage von
Heizung ist kein Kulturkampf das sind
erstmal ganz
ganz reguläre Themen politische Themen
über die wir diskutieren
und das erleben wir gerade
damit sie sind Themen die zu
gesellschaftlicher Spaltung führen wenn
sie sozusagen bearbeitet werden in einer
Art und Weise die eben auch eher
spaltend ist in der Sprache in der
Auseinandersetzung übrigens durchaus
auch gelegentlich von von auch beiden
Seiten wenn man wenn man Leuten die der
Meinung sind Migration sollte begrenzt
sein weil wir nicht unendlich leisten
können wenn man Leuten die der Meinung
sind
zum Beispiel eben dass es zwei
biologische Geschlechter gibt wenn man
Leuten die der Meinung sind sie möchten
in Ihrer Nachbarschaft keine die Tipp
Moschee haben aus der Türkei finanziert
wenn man den Leuten sagt dass sie recht
sind
dann kann es passieren dass ein Teil von
denen sagt ja dann werde ich halt rechts
und das glaube ich ist auch die Frage
wie wir politische Auseinandersetzung
machen aber wenn eine politische
Auseinandersetzung in der Sache machen
die das Argument sucht die sich auch in
der Sache reibt oder ob wir eine
politische Auseinandersetzung haben und
ich finde die haben wir zu oft die ganz
schnell im emotionalen im moralischen
ist und am Ende eben ganz schnell
zuordnet und sie haben damit nichts zu
tun
mit dieser Zuspitzung genau mit mit mit
der mit dem Mechanismus den sie gerade
beschreiben nein ich suche die Debatte
in der Sache klar in der Sache oder im
Kulturkampf in der Sache noch mal ja
also den Leuten wird gesagt
ihr erfahrt das falsche Auto ihr habt
das falsche Haus ihr habt die falsche
Heizung überhaupt noch ein Haus er ist
das falsche Essen ihr habt die falsche
Einstellung und ein Mann hat einen Penis
und eine Frau nicht selbst diese Ansicht
gilt inzwischen in Teilen der
Ampelkoalition als problematisch
ich beschreibe erstmal einen Umstand das
ist ja so wer sagt das ist zig Millionen
Menschen also das ist das was ich erlebe
und das ist das was hier auch wenn sie
politisch einfach mal zusammen uns einen
Tag lang in den Bundestag setzen also im
Bundestag jemand sie und ich ja klar ist
da das Thema wissen Sie was für mich ist
interessant hinter dem heizungsgesetz
was ganz kurz sie dürfen der
interessanteste Teil diese diese Satz
ist für mich ist nicht die diese Penis
Fixierung und so weiter also Kulturkampf
untenrum quasi das falsche Essen die
falsche Heizung haben sie das Wort
glaube ich fünfmal in den Mund genommen
nicht ja ja ich sehe ja ja zitiere ja
nur den Leuten wird gesagt das ist das
was mich daran interessiert nee von wem
wird den Leuten in den Gesetzen steckt
indem sie das heizungsgesetz
ja klar wenn wenn man sagt wir machen
ein Werbeverbot für bestimmte
Lebensmittel wenn man sagt wir machen
regeln wer wie viel Fleisch essen darf
das ist ja auch das was man was man in
der ganzen Herleitung in der
Argumentationskette sieht ich sag noch
mal setzen wir uns zusammen mal einfach
einen Bundestag lauschenden reden und
dann werden sie oft das finden dann ist
das für mich mehr Kultur Verteidigung
dass man einfach sagt es gibt eine
breite Mehrheit in der Mitte in diesem
Land sich Millionen Menschen die einfach
Respekt verdienen ich meine dieser
Kanzler hat immer von Respekt für dich
das war seine Kampagne ich sehe im
Moment nicht nur nicht zum Kanzler ist
sie schon mal gar nichts von Respekt
gegenüber Millionen Lebens Entwürfen
Lebensleistung Ansichten die Menschen
haben und wir erlebende Politik an
vielen Stellen und übrigens in den
Sachfragen also dieses heizungsgesetz
über das wir gerade so viel diskutieren
ist ja nicht irgendwie eine kulturfrage
das ist eine ganz konkrete so zu
ökonomische Frage muss für viele
Menschen um zigtausend Euro geht diese
möglicherweise investieren müssen oder
nicht das ist ja nicht irgendwie das
Gefühl
das war sehr konkretes und es ist ja
erstmal verbunden mit der an- und
Aussage übrigens bis hin zu grünen die
sagen wir sollten keine
Einfamilienhäuser mehr im Land haben
dass die Ansage an viele Menschen ihr
lebt falscher
welche grünen sagen ihr sollt kann
Einfamilienhäusern haben eine die
Beraterinnen ich habe den Namen gerade
nicht zur Hand von Winfried Kretschmann
zum Beispiel in Baden-Württemberg wir
machen Faktencheck ist glaube ich eine
andere Sendung aber machen wir
anschließend hinterher hat gesagt dass
das Einfamilienhaus das eigene Auto das
ist die größte
hinteren die sie jetzt gerade sich raus
geteilt der Grünen aber es ist natürlich
das was an vielen Stellen in der grünen
und vor allem auch in dieser Ampel in
dieser ampelpolitik steckt das ist ja
ist ja sozusagen der Ansatz der sich
darin verbirgt diese Idee tatsächlich
bestimmte Dinge eben nicht mehr zu
wollen auch immer und das ist wissen wir
reden noch bis hierhin sachlich doch ich
sehe das andere Wahlen entschieden ne ja
wir verstehen mir darüber alle vier
Jahre ab im Deutschen Bundestag in den
Landtagen an anderen Stellen
das anders als die Grünen es ist völlig
legitim ist so zu sehen dann machen wir
Wahlen und dann sehen wir ja welche
Ansatz am Ende die größere Unterstützung
nochmal fragen also sie sagen die Grünen
wollen den Leuten die Häuser verbieten
ich frag sie wer und sie haben noch
nicht mal Namen für mich es ist das
Thema ist das ist das ist das genau das
ist das was ich meine genau dieses
zuspitzen im Moment sie sie sie wissen
nicht wer diese Frau ist ich weiß nicht
nur ihren Namen gerade nicht okay aber
wenn es so wichtig ist und man ist die
Grünen sind aber Herr lands wir können
jetzt einfach
mal eine Sendung Zeit mit Ihnen zusammen
das grünen Wahlprogramm dann gehen wir
einfach mal durch keine
Flächenversiegelung mehr heißt also im
Grunde keine Neubaugebiete mehr das
heißt bei mir in Münsterland exakt eines
es gibt keine neuen Einfamilienhäuser
mehr die Frage wie teuer man es macht
überhaupt ein Haus zu bauen auch über
Energieeffizienz Richtlinien und die
Frage wer sich das dann noch leisten
kann und wenn nicht ist die Frage ob
Eigentumswohnungen und Einfamilienhäuser
noch möglich sind diese ganze Idee
irgendwie sich was zu erarbeiten ohne
dass man vom Staat irgendwie eine
Förderung braucht wäre es nicht wäre es
nicht ist aber nur eine Frage ja
einfach die Programmatik nein es geht um
die programmatisch
wir sind bei Winnetou und wir sind bei
der Frage wie viele geschlechtliche
moment
mal sie wollen doch eine Kraft der Mitte
sein und sie haben doch auch gerade eine
riesige Verantwortung in diesem Land
also sie entscheiden doch maßgeblich
darüber mit ob sie genau diesen Sound
der genau zu solchen Wahlergebnisse
führt ob sie den befeuern oder ob sie
sagen wir sollten eine mäßige Stimme
sein wir sollten versuchen möglichst in
der Mitte Ausgleich zu schaffen das
entscheiden sie doch wäre es nicht
seriöser in dem Punkt nur weil sie das
jetzt spontan
das ganze mit dem Haus geht ja zurück
auf Hamburg Nord wenn ich das richtig im
Kopf Norderstedt war es in Hamburg
Norderstedt gibt es schlicht und
ergreifend das Thema und es ist glaube
ich in Münster das gleiche Thema
vielleicht weiß Professor nativ da
besser Bescheid es gibt schlicht den
Platz nicht mehr für Einfamilienhäuser
es gibt schlicht den Platz nicht mehr
das ist was ganz anderes als ein Verbot
von Einfamilienhäusern also erstmal
jetzt haben sie zehn Thema auf einmal
können auf einmal darf ich kurz mal der
Reihe nach ja ich darf aber einmal kurz
noch mal sagen wenn man hier in Hamburg
lebt dann gibt's natürlich Gebiete da
können sie nicht mehr bauen ja das sie
können jetzt nicht Mehrfamilienhaus
abreißen und ein Einzelhaus dahinter bei
der Wohnungsnot die wir haben und da
gibt's tatsächlich in Hamburg ja aber
wenn ich schon mal das Wort habe dann
würde ja dann würde ich aber doch in
Richtung Kulturkampf entspannen noch mal
fragen wie kann es gehen dass sie die
narrative der AFD wiederholen ich finde
sie verweisen immer auf die Ampel ja die
haben alles falsch gemacht die sind
verantwortlich für den Aufstieg der AFD
aber dass Leute von ihnen sagen
heizhammer oder gesinnungstaat ja das
sind Worte die von ihren Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ja Gesinnung Stasi all diese
Geschichte oder Heizung Stasi ich weiß
gar nicht was alles kommt das ist für
mich völlig unakzeptabel und ich finde
genau das was Markus Lanz gerade gesagt
hat sie sollten doch gerade versuchen
ein Gegenpol gerade auch was sozusagen
die Anrede der Bevölkerung angeht
darstellen und nicht sozusagen in die
gleiche Kerbe hauen mit den gleichen
schlimmen Worten muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen warum gibt es da nicht mehr
Widerstand zu Verlauf von ihnen ich
hoffe dass sie nicht solche Worte
benutzen also jetzt haben sie beiden
ganz viele Themen auf einmal aufgemacht
hoffentlich auch eine halbe Minute was
sagen Herz zum ersten ich widerspreche
wie im Moment der These dass die
politische Auseinandersetzung über
Themen wie die heizungsgesetzgebung und
das was wir dazu sagen irgendwie dazu
führt dass es solche Wahlergebnisse gibt
ne das ist schon eine Bundesregierung
die von ihrem ganzen Ansatz her bei
diesem Gesetz alles überfordert zu
überfordert die Menschen mit der Ansage
ab dem ersten 24 ist erstmal vieles
anders in den Fristen sie überfordert
das parlamentarische Verfahren stand
heute wissen wir immer noch nicht über
was wir nächste Woche abstimmen sollen
etwas was Millionen Menschen betrifft
jeder hat eine Heizung zu Hause sie
überfordert sich selbst in einem
täglichen Streit den wir seit Monaten
erleben und das alles zusammen führt
dazu dass die Menschen massiv Vertrauen
verlieren wir haben gleichzeitig
AFD Weiler was haben die denn gesagt
warum sie AFD wählen ich würde übrigens
mal bevorzugen nicht eine Sendung nach
dem anderen über die AFD zu machen
vielleicht sollten wir weniger über die
höcke Partei reden und etwas mehr über
die Themen aber bitte schön ich hatte
nämlich am Ende machen das vor allem sie
noch stärker dass wir den ganzen Tag uns
nur mit denen beschäftigen aber
unabhängig davon wenn man schauen warum
wählen die denn viele vielfach die AFD
Migration ist ein großes Thema dass sie
in den Städten und gemeint stören wir
laufen in einer Überforderung hinein bzw
sind schon drin das Thema Klimaschutz
heizungsgesetz und heizhammer also wenn
das jetzt schon irgendwas ist was man in
der politischen Debatte in Deutschland
nicht mehr sagen kann ich würde so ein
paar Sprachräume sollten wir uns
miteinander schon noch aufhalten absolut
und das dritte Thema ist alles das
dritte ist Inflation im
Durchschnittsverdiener in Deutschland
mit 4000 Euro brutto hat 4 500 Euro
netto pro Monat weniger an Kaufkraft das
treibt die Leute um gleichzeitig macht
diese Regierung ein Gesetz dass ich
völlig anders es geht nicht darum dass
wir irgendwie freundlich darüber reden
wenn wir regieren wird es ein solches
Gesetz nicht geben bzw das wird wieder
abgeschafft und geändert wir sehen das
in der Sache fundamental anders diesen
ganzen Angaben die Dinge verbieten zu
wollen diesen ganzen Angang nur über die
Wärmepumpe zu gehen und alles andere im
Grunde nicht in den Blick zu nehmen
diesen ganzen anderen die Menschen in
den Fristen zu überfordern das ist eine
harte politische Auseinandersetzung in
der Sache und genauso führen wir Sie
auch und wenn ich dann lese ja wir
müssen nur etwas besser erklären wissen
was wir vorhaben nee es geht nicht darum
dass sie es mehr oder wem auch immer
besser erklären müssen wir wollen das so
nicht und wenn das nicht verstanden wird
in der Ampel dass man auf Dauer keine
Politik gegen die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung machen kann und das gilt
übrigens so ein paar Politikfelder dann
wird es noch sehr echt schwere Zeiten
geben okay die eine sehr versierte
politische Beobachterin und die was
denkt wenn Sie das hört also sozusagen
ist ist die These richtig dass wir da
tatsächlich auf so eine auf so eine
Polarisierung auf seine Zuspitzung
zulaufen und noch mal ich finde es gut
dass wir uns streiten und mit ihr
entspannt kann man sich mal großartig
streiten das finde ich wunderbar und
gerne auch gleich noch mehr davon aber
in der in der sozusagen objektiven
Auseinandersetzung über das was der
richtige Weg ist auf dem Weg zu dem was
wir erreichen wollen und es ist ja auch
steht gar nicht in der Regel auch eine
CDU geführte Regierung auch ein
Bundeskanzler Schmerz hat Peter Altmaier
neulich hier in der Sendung darauf
hingewiesen der hätte die gleiche
Aufgabe er muss bis 2045 dieses Land
klimaneutral machen ist völlig egal was
er über Wärmepumpen erzählt und ist auch
ganz egal wie entspannargumentiert hätte
die gleiche Aufgabe das heißt worauf
läuft es denn da hinaus was passiert
was im Moment Interessantes zu
beobachten ist das jetzt auch die CDU
ähnlich wie die Grünen ihre Flügel
Kämpfe hat es gibt einen wüst und einen
deine Günther Flügel das ist so der
mittige Flügel der CDU in der Sprache
eher moderat verbindend
mit grünen in ihren Bundesländern und
dann gibt es den März Flügel der eben
versucht unter anderem auch die AFD
wieder zurück zur CDU zu holen und der
sich dabei einer sehr robusten Sprache
verdient und Jens Spahn das ist
zumindest so meine Beobachtung
positioniert sich so dazwischen in der
Sache
sind sie eher mit ich jetzt sagen in der
Mitte angesiedelt sie haben in NRW den
Koalitionsvertrag mitverhandelt
sprachlich aber sind sie eher auf der
Seite von März eben dieses dem Volk aufs
Maul schauen um das umgangssprachlich zu
sagen quasi die Leute mit ihren
Problemen die klar zu benennen und dabei
dann auch bestimmte Dinge rauszupicken
eben die sie an den Grünen dann stören
die Grünen haben einen Hang zum
Mikromanagement das ist glaube ich Fakt
also das bestreitet auch in Berlin
niemand sie wollen möglichst viel im
Detail schon vorgeben und das will die
CDU nicht und die CDU da kann man sich
komplett anderer Meinung sein das ist ja
völlig in Ordnung
pickt sich dann eben auch bestimmte
Dinge raus die dann dieses narrativ
quasi verstärken also wenn in einem
Bebauungsplan ein grüner Bezirksrat sagt
keine Einfamilienhäuser mehr dann ist
das ein familienhausverbot
wenn in einer Ernährungsempfehlung von
Cem Özdemir steht das in
Gemeinschaftseinrichtungen in Schulen
vielleicht an zwei Tagen kein Fleisch
gegessen werden sollte dann ist das das
fleischverbot also das wird dann so
überhöht um quasi diesen
Kulturkampf der da stilisiert wird dann
zu nähren und das halte ich insofern für
problematisch weil ja auch so ein
bisschen die Frage ist wo will die CDU
damit hin mit dieser Sprache die CDU hat
aus meiner Sicht außer schwarz rot und
wenn sie nicht wieder zurück zur großen
Koalition wollen nicht mehr so viele
macht Optionen Schwarz-Gelb wird es auf
absehbare Zeit wahrscheinlich nicht
geben also läuft das auf Schwarz-Grün
hinaus das Modell wie Henrik wüst
regiert wie Daniel Günther regiert und
das passt dann schwierig schwer zusammen
wenn sie sich dann auf der einen Seite
verbal so in diesem Kulturkampf
reingehen aber auf der anderen Seite
schwarz grün tatsächlich die einzig
realistische Machtposition für die grüne
ist also zum ersten
finde ich mal wir sollten nicht unsere
Programmatik und unsere Positionierung
jetzt irgendwie daran festmachen will
mit wem wir möglicherweise koalieren
oder nicht koalieren
unser Hauptgegner sind die Grünen
schwarz grün also der Gegner sind für
Sie die Grünen nicht die AFD nein das
beides politische Gegner ist erstmal
diese Regierung beides klar wir wollen
wieder
darf ich mal erstmal kurz die sind immer
schon wieder drei Themen auf das eine
Mann
verlieren
gerade
in der politische Gegner sind die Grünen
und ich frage gesagt ja ja ja auch er
sagt also schwarz grün ist natürlich
automatisch sind grüne und im übrigen
aus meiner Sicht auch diese ganze Ampel
von diesem Scholz siehste gar nichts das
heißt der immer was Olaf will das ist
das ja hier in Hamburg immer OWD stand
ja auf den Akten Olaf will dass ich sage
immer weh oh wo ist Olaf an der
an dieser Stelle das natürlich ist und
die Bundesregierung unserer politischer
Gegner und den Grünen im Moment
insbesondere weil das die bundesgrün
muss man jetzt mal sagen im Moment auf
so einem Weg der Ideologisierung sind
also sie machen ja auch aus Klimaschutz
auch aus anderen Themen wieder eine
Frage des Glaubens und weniger eine
Frage der Vernunft meine feste
Überzeugung ist Klimaschutz muss man ein
Vernunft machen Klimaschutz ist eine
Frage des Guten Handwerks und nicht des
guten Glaubens allein so da haben wir in
der Sache in der Umsetzung in der Art
wie man auf Mensch und Gesellschaft
blicken ziemlich großen Unterschied und
ja deswegen gibt's da eine politische
Auseinandersetzung nur weil man
miteinander koaliert im übrigen ist man
ja nicht auf einmal eine Partei und im
Bund schon mal gar nicht und deswegen
arbeiten wir die Unterschiede raus und
zweiten das hatte ich gerade begonnen zu
sagen Herr Lanz äh sollten wir ja nicht
aus koalitionsüberlegung heraus unsere
programmatiker Arbeiten die CDU ist die
Partei der sozialen Marktwirtschaft eben
nicht der Planwirtschaft und der Verbote
die CDU ist die Partei des starken
Staates des Rechtsstaates wenn es egal
ob Klang Kriminalität ob äh
klimaaktivisten die sich Känguru
festkleben Extremismus rechts wie links
gibt es Unterschiede aber gleichermaßen
sind sie zu bekämpfen durch den
Rechtsstaat eine Partei die gesteuerte
Migration will weiß dass es grenzendes
Machbaren des Möglichen gibt gerade auch
beim Thema Migration bevorzugt in den
Arbeitsmarkt nicht in die Sozialsysteme
das sind ich könnte jetzt munter
weitermachen ein ganz vielen Themen
machen Sie doch mal das sind unsere
Sendung gesagt
erstmal normal diese Themen auch zum
Ausdruck zu bringen und ja auch
Unterschiede rauszuarbeiten ich weiß
manchmal gar nicht was ist eigentlich
mit der politischen Debatte in
Deutschland passiert dass wenn man jetzt
schon sagt sozusagen ja vereinfachend
aber im Zweifel passiert sowas ja vor
allem auch auf Parteitags reden wenn man
nicht mal mehr ein paar politische
Sachverhalte vereinfachen darf hin zu
das ist ein äh das ist ein Heizungs
Hammer oder das ist ein ein Gott weiß
was verboten das Wort klimadiktatur in
den Mund genommen Energie
wir können über jedes einzelne Wort
streiten aber ich finde halt am Ende des
Tages
Diktaturen auch nicht mehr formulieren
weil ich ja dann an der
Auseinandersetzung gemerkt habe dass
dann alles nur noch sich auf das eine
Wort fokussiert was dahinter steckt ist
ja genau das was ich eingangs wo sie
mich zitiert haben gesagt habe das ist
so der Ansatz ihr fahrt das falsche Auto
ihr habt das falsche Haus ihr habt die
falsche Heizung falsch
und wir schreiben euch das jetzt
staatlich vor weil wir wissen es besser
und das wie sie schon gesagt haben so
eine Art Mikro Management am Ende im
Alltag der Menschen wahnsinnig stark und
wo viele halt einfach sagen da habe ich
keinen Bock drauf und das ist das reicht
ihn als Programm ich habe doch gerade
ziemlich viele Punkte inhaltliche Art
gesagt von der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
über den Rechtsstaat nochmal ein paar
Partei wir können auch gerne noch mal
über die Frage Europäern
wie fanden sie wie fanden sie eigentlich
die Rede von Claudia Pechstein auf auf
Ihrer Veranstaltung neulich die war okay
ich teile nicht jeden Satz aber ich
finde das sind alles Dinge die man sagen
kann und auch sagen können
Sie brillant ich fand es okay also nicht
brillant ich muss ich weiß nicht sind
Sie immer alles so wie ich weiß nicht
wer ist denn eigentlich ihr Vorsitzender
auf jeden Fall sie hat nur Vorsitzende
unterscheiden uns in der Wortwahl ich
finde erstmal da wieder
gewundert hat wie schnell da auch schon
wieder alle so auf der Moral und
Bewertungsebene sind dann schaut man
doch einfach mal was hat Pechstein
gesagt in der Sache
immer das Beste
rein und dann stellen wir uns vielleicht
noch mal die Frage ob das wirklich die
Dinge sind um dies eigentlich gerade
geht
komm und Asyl beantragen und ein Richter
nach Prüfung
dann versteht niemand dass solche
Menschen einfach hier bleiben dürfen
allein die öffentliche rechtlichen
Verkehrsmittel zu nutzen zu können ohne
ängstliche Blicke nach links und rechts
werfen zu müssen gehört zum Beispiel er
gehört zu den Alltagsproblem die viele
besonders ältere Menschen unter Frauen
belasten hierfür Verbesserung zu sorgen
sollte uns grundsätzlich 100 mal
wichtiger sein als darüber nachzudenken
ob wir einen gender Sternchen setzen
oder auch ein Konzert noch deutscher
Liederabend heißen da
oder ob es noch erlaubt ist ein
Zigeunerschnitzel zu bestellen die
Kinder hierzulande wollen nicht nur
einen guten Job eine heile Familie eine
traditionelle Familie sie wollen Mama
und Papa
die Familienpolitik der christlichen
demokratischen Union sollte sich
grundsätzlich zuallererst mit der
traditionellen Familie beschäftigen weil
wir aufhören die familienparteien im
Lande zu sein dann werden wir auch nicht
mehr Volkspartei in Deutschland sein
[Applaus]
die Frage war ja sind das neben der
jetzt darf ich kurz was sagen das war
ihre Frage wann sind das relevante
Themen müssen sie ich war glaube ich als
einer von wenigen als pegida begonnen
hat ich weiß genau wann es war bestimmt
schon 10 Jahre her in Dresden ich war in
Dresden zu einer Veranstaltung der
politischen
Landeszentrale für politische Bildung da
vor Ort und wissen die das Thema dass
ich nicht beantworten konnte den Leuten
zufriedenstellen schon damals war warum
setzt ihr Recht nicht durch warum sind
Menschen wo bis zum Ende ein
Gerichtsurteil sagt sie müssen das Land
verlassen zum Teil Jahre später noch im
Land und bekommen auch unterstützen
Widerspruch ja aber sie sagten ja gerade
sind das Themen sind das Themen die
Leute bewegen das ist eines
nicht so nicht so drehen das nicht mein
Thema mein Thema ist was vollkommen
anderes mein Thema ist ein bisschen
Aufrichtigkeit an dem Punkt wir sollten
uns ehrlich machen es war ihre CDU ihre
CDU geführte Bundesregierung die das
nicht den Griff gekriegt hat wir sind
mich nicht alles täuscht Herr Land sind
wir tatsächlich abgewählt worden
wahrscheinlich unter anderem
ganz im Gegenteil es bestärkt gerade das
was ich sage ja aber das Argument
natürlich
erstmal an dem Problem nicht und ja auf
wir haben verantwortlich
ja ich habe gerade zugehört habe ich ja
gerade gesagt ich konnte den Menschen in
Dresden schon vor zehn Jahren nicht eine
mich selber zufriedenstellende Antwort
geben auf die Frage warum sind die
eigentlich noch im Land so und die
Wahrheit ist ja wir haben das bis heute
nicht gelöst es ist ein Problem und
Probleme die man nicht löst das geht in
der Familie in der Beziehung das geht
politisch die holen ein meistens Frucht
und deswegen ist das was ganz kurz da
sieht da steht eine Polizeibeamtin in
dieser Uniform besteht dann da oben und
sagt einfach mal entspannt
Zigeunerschnitzel
warum und will Gespenster vertreiben die
außer ihnen keiner sieht der Preis
findet brillant also Hellern ist er
wirklich hat dieses Land keine anderen
Probleme außer elende gender Sternchen
Zigeunerschnitzel Radwege in Berlin all
diese Themen
öffentlich-rechtliche Verkehrsmittel das
Böse öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen
geänderte heute kam es wieder geänderte
Nachrichtensendungen
ihre Parteivorsitzender hat es mir vor
einigen Wochen aufgefallen sagte
irgendwie jeder geänderte Nachrichten
Satz in einem öffentlich rechtlichen
Fernsehsender führt dazu dass wieder
hunderte Stimmen rübergehen zu AFD ganz
kurz
weder in der Tagesschau noch in der
heute noch im heute journal noch in den
Tagesthemen noch hier
gendert irgendjemand dabei Land das ist
genau das was ich meine das ist genau
die Sache die Grünen wollen euch das
Haus verbieten von einer Frau deren
Namen Sie noch nicht mal kennenlernt
haben ich weiß nicht in den letzten 20
Minuten sie nicht ich sie gefühlte 20
mal in den Mund genommen das Wort Penis
haben sie fünf Mal in den Mund genommen
der die Frage Kulturkampf haben sie
zehnmal in dem Moment weil ich darüber
mit Ihnen gerne reden
ihre wertvolle Sendezeit in einem der
besten Sendeplätze des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehens nicht
um über Inflation
darüber gesprochen und über Inflation
Klima heizungsgesetz über die Themen zu
reden ja stimme zu es ist nicht das
Thema der Republik aber warum verwenden
wir dann hier auf ihre Initiative hin
gerade so viele sind nicht das Thema der
Republik ja haben sie gerade gesagt
aus meiner Sicht nicht das Thema das auf
die Tagesordnung gehört ja das ist
interessant das Problem ist nur das ist
immer es ist doch am Ende eine Reaktion
die Frage Gendern oder nicht im
öffentlich rechtlich ja oder überhaupt
im öffentlichen Raum ist übrigens jemand
privat bei sich zu Hause oder in seinem
Unternehmen war immer macht es sowieso
egal es geht ja hier um den öffentlichen
öffentlich-rechtlichen dem Bereich wo
Start oder öffentlich-rechtlich agiert
Themen wie 218 abtreibungsparagraph wo
wir in sehr mühsam gefundenen Kompromiss
in Deutschland haben an der befriedet
ist Selbstbestimmungsrecht die Frage ob
man einmal im Jahr sein Geschlecht nur
durch einen Sprechakt ändern kann oder
nicht das sind ja nicht unsere Ideen das
sind ja nicht nein nicht so dass wir
diese Debatten anfangen aber man kann
von der bürgerlichen CDU und nicht
verlangen dass wir bei diesen Debatten
einfach regungslos daneben stehen und
nichts dazu